قالت رئاسه التركيه انه تم الاتفاق مع
السويد وفنلندا وحلف شمال الاطلسي على
مواصله العمل بشان خطوات انضمام السويد
للحلف من جهته قال كبير مفاوضيه الوفد
السويدي ان بلاده ليست ملاذا امنا للارهاب
او لحزب العمال الكردستاني مضيفا ان
مفاوضات السويد مع تركيا بشان عضويه
النايتو سوف تستمر واشار الى ان هدف
الحكومه السويديه ما زال ان تصبح السويد
عضوا في النيتو باسرع ما يمكن
وكانت الاليه المشتركه دائما متعلقه
بانضمام السويد الى النيتو قد عقدت اليوم
او عقدت اليوم اجتماعها الرابع في انقره
من جانبه قال الامين العام لحلف الاطلس
شمال
الاطلسمبرغ ان المحادثات بشان انضمام
السويد الى الناتو احرزت بعض التقدم واضاف
ان السويد اجرى التعديلات في دستورها
وعززت قوانين محاربه الارهاب وان الوقت قد
حان ليتفق الاطراف جميعا على تصديق على
انضمامها
التقيت بالرئيس اردوغان في اسطنبول قبل
اسبوعين تحدثنا عن عضويه السويد واتفقنا
على دعوه اللجنه المشتركه بين السويد
وتركيا وممثلين نيتو التي تجري المشاورات
وتحدثت الى رئيس هذه اللجنه قال ان
الاجتماع جرى في جو بناء وتم تحقيق تقدم
وسنستمر في العمل من اجل التصديق على
عضويه السويد بالسرعه الممكنه
وينضم الينا من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج عمر اهلا بك عمر كيف يتطور الموقف
التركي من موضوع عندما السويد الى حلف
الناتو بناء على تصريحات الرئاسه التركيه
نعم خديجه التصريح الذي اصدرته دائره
الاتصال في الرئاسه التركيه والذي يتحدث
عن عزم تركيا استمرار اللقاءات مع الاليه
الرباعيه المشتركه بين كل من تركيا وحلف
الناتو اضافه الى كل من فنلندا والسويد
وانه قال ان تركيا تنظر بايجابيه الى
التعديلات التي اقرت في السويد في الاول
من يونيو المصرم ولكن على الى هذا القدر
توقف هذا البيان الذي كان مقتضبا جدا اذا
اردنا اعاده قراءه الموقف التركي ربما
نستطيع العوده الى تصريحات التي صدرت
اليوم قبيل انتهاء هذا الاجتماع من الرئيس
البرامي الذي ادلى بهذه التصريحات عند
عودته من اذربيجان وقال ان موقف تركيا لن
يتغير على الاقل في هذه في ضوء المعطيات
الحاليه حيال انضمام السويد الى حلف
الناتو قال ان اول ان اول اجتماع عقده
اردوغان بعد اعاده تنصيبه ايام مع الامين
حلف في شمال الاطلسي ياسين سلطنه وحضره
مسؤولون اتراكم على راسهم كان ايضا رئيس
الجديد
للاستخبارات التركيه ابراهيم كولندا حين
في وقت هذا الاجتماع في وقت متسام لهذا
الاجتماع كان هناك مظاهره في ستوكه من من
تسميهم تركيا بانهم عناصر ارهابيه
المصنف ارهابيا في البلاد وان ابراهيم
تواصل حينها مع نظيره السويدي احيانا
وسجلتراضه على هذه التظاهرات يبدو ان
يقولن حتى الان تركيا لم تلمس تعديلا يفضي
الى القضاء على هذه المجموعات الارهابيه
التي تشن اعمالا على الحدود التركيه
السوريه وهي مضره بالامن القومي التركي
وحاله حدوث هذه التعديلات سوف تقدم تركيا
على خطوات الايجابيه ولكنه قال بالحرف ان
ما تزال الخطوات الصلبه كما وصفها المطلوب
من السويد
بها حتى الان لم تنفذ وعليه قال ان موقف
تركيا من اجتماع القادم الذي سيحدث سيحصل
في ليتوانيا ما يزال قائما وان تركيا لن
ترفع امتعاضها او تحفظها على على انضمام
السويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن مره
اخرى هذه ربما هذا الموقف الصلب المصر على
وجود التحفظ قد يكون هناك تغيير في اجتماع
الذي انتهى قبل قليل بالمناسبه والذي اطفى
نوعا من الايجابيه على الموقف التركي لا
ينتظر على الاقل رسميا من الجانب التركي
ان يغير موقفه في اجتماع الحلف القادم
هناك رغبه في استمرار هذه الاليه
الاستماره اجتماعات هذه الاليه ولكن حتى
الان على الاقل لم يحدد موعدها ولا اين
سوف تعقد بالمناسبه هذا هو الاجتماع
الرابع لهذه الاليه والتي افضت بعد اجتماع
بعد ثلاث اجتماعات الى رفع تركيا تحفظها
على انضمام وهذا ما حدث ولكن تقول ان هناك
خط وات يجب ان تتخذها السويد في هذا السبب
شكرا لك عمر الحاج مراسلنا